well you think about it the left says  that freedom is putting on 10 masks and  getting you know 15 000 boosters which  are you know the Ayatollah says that as  well that putting on masks is freedom  yeah  yeah that's right so you know you get  you get these different definitions of  freedom and even job I bet Joe Biden  would tell you if he came back to his  alma mater I bet he would tell you I'm  for freedom and and I think there are  all these sorts of debates you even see  it a little bit on the right and it's a  it's a big misunderstanding because true  freedom is not just the ability to do  whatever you want whenever you want to  do it if true true Freedom were the  ability to do whatever you want whenever  you want to do it you know who the  freest person in the world would be who  it would be a heroin addict oh yeah  right a sort of but derelict bum  shooting up heroin on the street we're  only about 30 minutes away from  Kensington Avenue